so just like we've been telling you joe
biden's america last policies are
designed to pander to the rest of the
world
you pay the bill of course taking aim at
you
we the american people we're all going
to suffer we're all going to pay a lot
more for everything
we're now learning that biden's rollback
of donald trump's highly successful
remain in mexico policy will now allow
asylum seekers get this
those that were ordered to be deported
for not attending their court hearings
to
enter the u.s interior and restart their
proceedings in other words
they went home they're inviting them
back and they're even apparently paying
for transportation
now that is open borders leading into
amnesty plain and simple
and then of course biden's failures
don't stop there
as the administration is still refusing
to hold china accountable
and refusing to be honest about well the
communist chinese role in covering up
the true origins of the coronavirus
and get this we're now learning that
even google was reportedly involved in
funding research by the now
infamous eco health alliance that
received u.s
taxpayer dollars and subcontracted with
the
wuhan virology lab on gain of function
research so i'll ask again
when is the biden administration going
to be transparent
start being honest with you the american
people about all the evidence supporting
not only the lab league theory that the
democrats and the media said was a
conspiracy theory and lied about
but also it appears american dollars may
have helped fund this
here with reaction south carolina
senator lindsey graham senator let me
start first at the border
uh i'll be down at the border next week
on wednesday with president trump
with governor abbott uh i understand
there's a chance you may be going as
well
uh we're we're doing a town hall when
we're down there
it's the number one issue we're now
headed for two and a half million people
illegally in coming into the country and
now they're being
eight now they're being transported to
every state in the country
and people now have to pay for food and
clothing and shelter and housing and
education
how would you deal with this well number
one the biden harris
administration is incompetent and
foolish when it comes to managing
illegal immigration
they're literally telling people that
we've sent to mexico
because they didn't show up for their
asylum hearing
hey you can come back and start over
again the biden administration supports
eliminating cash bail
basically letting everybody out look at
what's happened in new york
the cops arrest a guy monday morning
they're out monday afternoon
so all these policies are blowing up in
the biden
uh harris administration's face is six
months since they've been in charge
let's name the winners in the last six
months drug cartels
in mexico human traffickers and coyotes
in mexico the taliban in afghanistan
the iranian ayatollah russia
putin and china have all been the
biggest winners
of incompetent domestic and foreign
policy
okay we knew that the the wuhan virology
lab
studied coronaviruses we knew that they
were involved in gain of function
research
we knew all of this right anthony fauci
knew this
and anthony fauci was told that a
certain
genome indicated that the gain of
function
uh procedures were taken place on covert
19
on january 31st 2020 then he had
panicked emails about whether or not the
nih helped fund it
right knowing what we know is there any
doubt
that gain of function research caused
this virus
at that wuhan lab
there's no doubt in my mind i think i
could prove beyond a reasonable doubt
that the virus came from a lab not from
a bat to an animal
into human beings that the way and
mueller
analysis of the case here five
fingerprints proving it came out of the
lab you could convict somebody in a
court of law
so what do we need to do we need to
allow the american people to go to an
american court
and sue the chinese communist party for
ruining their lives and their businesses
by waiving sovereign immunity
like we did after 9 11 for saudi arabia
so i'm going to challenge my democratic
colleagues
to open the american court system up so
we can get to the bottom of what
happened in china
the best way to get to the truth is to
have a trial over where it came from and
how it got to america
and i'm convinced this came from a lab
leak i don't think it was an
intentional but it didn't come from
nature and i hope you'll have way
and mueller on your show to explain to
your viewers
why they believe beyond a doubt that it
came
from the lab all right senator sr1 is
now
officially dead we now have senator
cinema
and joe manchin on record saying they
would not abolish
the legislative filibuster uh apparently
you were taking part in
in bipartisan discussions uh on
infrastructure not something i would
have advised you to do i think you're
wasting your time
but nobody ever listens to sean hannity
trust me i try to advise a lot of people
a lot of people actually do but the
question now is
is this new green deal socialist agenda
dead can republicans
more importantly will republicans unite
and
stop it good question okay we know
what's dead
the power grab to take over the
elections by the federal government
is dead because we stopped it today
now if they do reconciliation to pass
the green new deal
we'll see where manchin and cinema are
on that what i'm offering my democratic
colleagues
is a trillion plus dollars paid for
infrastructure as we know it roads
bridges and ports
electrical vehicles they can be in the
mix that we can find a pathway forward
for trillion dollars
for infrastructure but we're not going
to find a pathway forward
for six trillion dollars of spending in
the name of
infrastructure so i'm hoping that
moderate democrats will
me and others to find a solution and
they will reject a six trillion dollar
takeover of the country
i'll say this senator uh 2022
florida georgia south carolina senator
scott
north carolina new hampshire wisconsin
ohio arizona
all those senate seats are up for grabs
those
that this race in 2022 it's all
on the line leading into 2024. all right
senator thank you hey sean hannity here
hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else